Good evening, and welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
Let me just start by saying
that the crowd tonight is
bigger than the crowd that
Paula Poundstone brought
in last night.
Good for you folks.
[APPLAUSE]
Before I introduce
our speaker tonight,
I just want to
mention that today
Adam Block, he does the
astronomy at Mount Lemmon
Science Center, has some
incredible photographs that he
has taken.
And if you want to have the
photographs signed by him,
you have to buy them today.
So on the way out, he's
out there waiting for you
to buy all his photographs.
They really are
truly extraordinary
and just don't run out.
I always acknowledge
all of those folks that
pay so that all of
us don't have to pay
to listen to our speakers.
And today, I'd just like
to mention, in particular,
the Galileo Circle.
Each evening we do acknowledge
all of these folks.
The Galileo Circle members
support the College of Science,
and monies that they give to
the College of Science support
undergraduate students.
And this year 80 students
were supported generously
because of the support
of these folks,
and I thank you
very much for that.
[APPLAUSE]
And I also want to
thank those of you that,
because of the lecture series,
have joined the Galileo Circle.
There were some of
you that did that.
And I want to thank, indeed,
all of our donors, Galileo
Circle or not, for sharing our
vision for research excellence,
novel teaching and outreach,
and creating opportunities
for our community.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Many of you may have
been here last week
when Turner was
talking about some
of the heroes of cosmology.
And he mentioned
that some of those
are actually here at the
University of Arizona.
And he chuckled that they did
their research at Chicago,
which was just a bad joke.
But one of those is
actually sitting right here.
David Arnett, would you
stand up for a second.
[APPLAUSE]
And if it wasn't for
David Arnett research,
we really wouldn't know if
our universe was expanding,
contracting, or whatnot,
because we really would
know how far these stars are.
He was the one that was able to
figure out luminosity in stars
and how that could be used to
determine if they were moving
away from us or not.
So David, good for you.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, today, we're going to hear
from one of my favorite faculty
members in the in the college,
Professor of Astronomy Phil
Pinto.
Phil was heavily into
fire crackers, gunpowder,
rocket engines, and all
things that are explosive.
So it was natural that after his
undergraduate work at Harvard,
he moved to the Lick
Observatory at UC Santa Cruz
to do graduate work on
supernova, the largest
explosions in the universe.
And just as he was finishing his
dissertation, remarkably still
with all his fingers,
the brightest supernova
in 400 years exploded
in a nearby galaxy.
Being at Santa Cruz, this
had nothing to do with pot.
It was the real stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
Phil shifted into high gear.
And with his advisory,
published the first paper
describing that
supernova and went on
to study this Rosetta Stone
for astronomers of wavelengths,
from the infrared to gamma rays.
He has since published
over 120 papers
on the physics of
stellar explosions,
high-energy density
plasmas in the laboratory,
techniques for computer
modeling in astrophysics,
and most certainly
on the formation
of large-scale structures
in the universe.
Phil is one of the founders
of the Large Synoptic Survey
Telescope.
This is the most important
new endeavor in astronomy,
as described by the National
Academy of Sciences.
It's an 8.4-meter telescope,
whose primary mirror is
currently in fabrication here
at the Steward Observatory Lab.
Phil will also be giving a
version of this talk on April
1st at the Mount
Lemmon Sky Center,
followed by an
evening of viewing
many of the celestial
objects you'll be
seeing in this lecture today.
You can find out more about
this event from Mount Lemon Sky
Center folks in the lobby.
And please help me welcome
Professor Phil Pinto.
[APPLAUSE]
Great.
Thank you.
Good evening.
For those of you who have been
here in the last few lectures,
I hope you believe by now the
universe began in a big bang
about a little less than
14 billion years ago.
And I thought I'd just give
you a little reprise of what
we've learned so far.
The universe began in an
unimaginably hot, unimaginably
tiny and dense knot and
expanded from much less
than the size of a
proton in much less
than a fraction of a second
up to a macroscopic size.
The expansion slowed
down somewhat after that
and continued for the
next 400,000 years.
The universe
expanded and cooled.
And eventually it got down
to about 5,000 degrees.
As Mike Turner told us
last time, at that point,
the protons and the electrons
in the gas began to recombine.
And he showed us that it
made the universe become
transparent, but there
was nothing to see,
and so this is the dark ages.
Well, the universe
continued to expand.
Matter began to clump together
under its own gravity.
And eventually, it formed
about 100 million years later,
the first stars.
And since that time,
stars and galaxies
have been forming continuously.
The peak rate of
that star formation
was about half the age
of the universe ago,
about 7 billion years ago.
And the universe has continued
to expand and cool ever since.
And most recently,
we've been seeing
the effect of dark energy,
causing the universe
to expand ever more rapidly.
And that leads us to today and
the subject of our lecture--
the contents of the cosmos.
Now, we've talked a
lot in this series
about how we don't know
a lot about the contents
of the universe.
Dark energy was only
discovered in the 1990s,
and yet it composes
most of the universe.
And we don't know where it
comes from or what it is.
Dark matter's been around
for the last 30 years
or so, in our knowledge, and
we still don't know what it is.
And together they make
up 95% of the universe.
[LAUGHTER]
But tonight, I'm here to talk
about the 5% that we do know--
[LAUGHTER]
--basically everything in the
universe that we can see around
us and the material, the kind
of normal matter that you
and I and planets and
stars are made of.
And so of that 5%,
almost all of it
is just hydrogen and helium gas
that comes out of the Big Bang.
Stars, the stuff we look
out and see as astronomers,
comprise only half a
percent of the universe.
The next third of a
percent is composed
of neutrinos, tiny
particles that travel
at nearly the speed of light.
And they interact very,
very weakly with matter.
These neutrinos can actually
pass right through the Earth
with hardly ever noticing it.
And we're not going to talk
about neutrinos quite yet,
but they'll play
a very major role
later on in the discussion.
And finally, we get to tonight's
topic, the heavy elements.
Heavy to an astronomer
means an element
that's not hydrogen or helium--
carbon, nitrogen, silicon,
oxygen, uranium,
everything else.
And they make up only 1/30
of 1% of the universe.
So you can either think of
that as a terribly small detail
or as very special, right?
I prefer to think
that quality is
more important than quantity.
So now some of you have gasped.
But you'll all remember
the periodic table
from your high school
chemistry course.
And this lays out the elements.
The elements, as you remember,
are the basic building blocks
of matter.
And here's a rather
fanciful diagram of an atom.
And each of the
elements is composed
of atoms of a given kind.
And here in our carbon
atom, we have a nucleus,
and remember Mike Turner told
us that protons are always red
and neutrons are always blue.
[LAUGHTER]
So here we have the nucleus
with six protons in red.
And the six protons
mean that it's carbon.
Each element has a
fixed number of protons
that say what the nuclear
charge of that element
is and gives it its name.
It also has six neutrons.
And if you add the 6 and 6,
even I can come up with 12,
and this is carbon-12.
And we'll get back
to that in a minute.
Surrounding the atom are
a bunch of electrons.
And atoms join together
to form molecules
and all the substances around
us by sharing electrons.
But that's chemistry.
I don't know anything
about chemistry.
So we're going to
stick to the nuclei
and find out where
the nuclei come from
and leave what happens
later to the chemists.
Now, I mentioned we
had carbon-12 there.
And that's an example of an
isotope-- the same number
of protons, because
the number of protons
tells you what element it
is, but different numbers
of neutrons.
So for example, here's
some hydrogen isotopes.
Plain hydrogen is
just one proton.
That's almost all the
hydrogen in the universe.
It does come in another flavor,
however, with one neutron,
and that's called deuterium,
or heavy hydrogen.
And there's still a third one.
It's got two neutrons
and a proton,
but you rarely see that
because it decays radioactively
in about 12 years, and
so it's quite rare.
It's called tritium.
Helium also has isotopes.
Most elements of isotopes.
And helium isotopes we'll
be talking about tonight
are the light helium--
two protons and a neutron,
helium helium-3.
And helium-4 is the
normal kind of helium,
two protons and two
neutrons-- so isotopes,
or same number of protons,
different number of neutrons.
Now, while we're doing a little
bit of a physics class here,
I want to talk about one
more thing that's important,
and that is heat.
What we macroscopically
think of as heat
is microscopically the
motion of particles.
And for tonight's
talk, the particles
will be the nuclei or
the atoms in a gas.
And so a cold gas is a bunch
of particles whizzing around.
But they're not whizzing
around very fast.
And they don't collide
all that often.
And when they do collide, they
don't collide that hard, right?
But if you heat that gas
up, they whiz faster.
They collide more frequently.
And when they collide, they
collide more energetically.
So cold gas is low speed,
fewer, weaker, collisions.
Hot gas is higher speeds,
more and stronger collisions.
Enough of physics.
Let's try doing some astronomy.
So let's, ask where did all this
stuff, the carbon, the oxygen,
the uranium, iron, all the
elements other than hydrogen
and helium, where
do they come from?
Well, we might try
with the Big Bang.
You might ask, did the Big Bang
produce that sort of stuff?
It produced all
the rest of matter.
Why shouldn't it have done that?
And we can try looking at
nucleosynthesis, the synthesis
of nuclei, in the Big Bang.
The way we start is to measure
the temperature of the universe
today.
And as Chris and Mike
have both told you,
that's about three
degrees above absolute 0,
minus 454 Fahrenheit.
So space is pretty cold.
And that's the cosmic
microwave background
that the WMAP
satellite measured.
We can also measure the
density of universe,
go out and measure the number of
stars, the number of galaxies,
the gas between the stars,
take all that mass that we see,
smear it all out, and
on average, the universe
contains about one
atom per cubic meter.
So the universe is very empty.
So now we can run
the universe backward
and see what can be made.
This is what's really neat
about being an astronomer.
Honey, what did you do
today at the office?
Oh, I ran the universe backward.
[LAUGHTER]
So back about three
minutes after the Big Bang,
the temperature's about
a billion degrees,
and the density
of the universe is
about like the air in this
room, about a thousandth
of a gram per cubic centimeter.
The universe is a
sea of particles,
in particular protons
and neutrons, the red
and blue particles
that we know about.
And they're whizzing
around because it's hot.
It's a billion degrees.
And hot gas has the
particles whizz around fast.
And some of these protons and
neutrons collide together,
and occasionally they stick
and they form a heavy hydrogen,
a deuterium nucleus.
And they give off some energy.
And Mike forgot to note
that energy is always
depicted by green squiggles.
[LAUGHTER]
Those are photons.
Now, once enough
deuterium is built up,
the deuteriums can collide
together, throw off a neutron,
and stick and form
some helium-3.
And some of that helium-3 can
collide with another deuteron
and throw off a proton
and form helium-4.
So there are lots
of particles running
around colliding into each
other, making new nuclei.
And basically, any
way you could think
of putting those
particles together
is actually happening there
in the early universe,
in the first few minutes.
And if you do a careful
calculation of all this,
what you come up with is that,
depending upon how much stuff
is in the universe, you make
a certain amount of helium,
a certain amount of deuterium,
a certain amount of helium-3,
and a certain amount of the
very light isotope of lithium-7.
If you put in the numbers
that we observed today
for the density
and the temperature
I talked about, what you
find is exactly what you
see when you go out and
measure how much helium there
is coming out of the Big Bang.
And this is one of the real
triumphs for the Big Bang
theory.
It was able to predict
the composition
of the universe, at least in
terms of the light elements
that we see today.
It makes about 24% helium.
Excuse me, my microphone
is falling off here.
It makes about 24% helium.
Most of the rest is
hydrogen and trace amounts
of these other light isotopes.
But it's a great triumph
for the Big Bang theory.
It's horrible for us.
Where's all the elements?
Where did all these
other elements come from?
So it didn't happen
in the Big Bang.
We've got to look elsewhere.
So let's look for some clues.
The first thing
we ought to do is
figure out what is it we're
actually trying to make.
What are all these elements?
So we could look at the Earth.
And when we look
at the Earth, we
find it's made mostly of oxygen
and silicon, calcium, and iron,
maybe a little bit of
potassium and aluminum,
sodium-- things that make rocks.
As you might imagine, the
Earth is made of rocks.
All these other
elements, some of which
you may have heard the names
of, are in much lower abundance,
all the way out to
uranium at the corner
there, which is the heaviest
naturally occurring element.
We could also look
at the human body.
A 70-kilogram adult
contains mostly oxygen,
a fair amount of
carbon and hydrogen,
little bit of nitrogen, calcium,
and pretty much all the rest
are vitamins, right?
[LAUGHTER]
And you know that's a
rather different sample
than the Earth.
Oxygen actually is the most
abundant element in your body
as well as in the Earth.
But where is all that iron?
Where's all that silicon?
We're not rocks.
And so this is a
different set of elements.
So we don't want this either.
This is not a representative
sample of the universe.
What we really need to do is do
what astronomers do, is go out
and look at the outer
layers of stars,
look at the gas between stars,
and look at its composition
and measure the
composition of rocks
that fall to Earth from
outer space-- meteorites.
And when you do that,
you put it all together,
you find this pattern here.
The universe is mostly
hydrogen and helium.
The next most
abundant element is
oxygen followed by carbon and
closely by iron, nitrogen,
and then all the rest
trailing off down here, again,
toward gold and uranium
at the bottom end.
So the question for
tonight really is,
how do we get from here, what
came out of the Big Bang,
to here, what we're made
of, or at least what
the solar system is made of?
Well, one clue is
that the oldest stars
are very deficient in
these heavy elements.
If you look at their
several thousand
older stars near the
Sun, you see some of them
here have almost no
heavy elements at all.
They're almost pure
hydrogen and helium.
And even a fair number
of them have only 1%
the amount of heavy
elements that the sun has.
So these stars must have formed
before the heavy elements were
made in the universe.
They must have formed out of
some primordial material that
hadn't been enriched
yet by whatever process
we're looking for tonight.
So much of nucleosynthesis must
have occurred since the oldest
stars were formed.
Another clue is that
the Sun has been
shining for 4.3 billion years.
It doesn't seem
like much of a clue,
but it'll become very
important in a moment.
And if you look at
this photograph,
you'll notice that there
that's not a sunspot.
That's the space
shuttle Atlantis
coming into dock with the
International Space Station.
It's an incredible
photograph taken
by a French amateur astronomer.
So if you think the formation of
elements has to do with stars,
you're right.
So let's talk a little
bit about how stars work.
Here's a wonderful image
from the Hubble Space
Telescope of some cold,
dense clouds of gas.
That's these things
depicted in brown.
And they are in the
process of forming stars.
Clumps of gas
inside these clouds
are separating out and
beginning to contract
into their own gravity.
As they contract, they
compress the gas in them.
And of course, gas when
you compress it, heats up.
And so they continue
to collapse.
They continue to
contract and heat up
until they get to be
hot enough to shine
in the visible part
of the spectrum.
At this point, we
call them protostars.
They're almost
stars but not quite.
And when they do
that, their light
begins to erode the
gas around them.
And you can see all these
wispy streamers coming off,
the white-colored
stuff coming off here,
into the warmer gas
surrounding, as this gas is
being blown away, revealing
these new stars that
are being formed.
And here's another image of a
similar star-forming region.
And this is not a
painting, right?
This is a real Hubble
Space Telescope image.
It's quite remarkable.
And here's another dark cloud.
You can see it going
diagonally across the image.
And those little stars in the
middle among the green stuff,
those are brand new stars,
only a few hundred thousand
or a million or so years old.
So we've got our protostar here.
It's collapsing.
It's getting hot.
If you want to make
a star out of it,
it's got to stop collapsing.
It's got to sit there.
It's got to last
for a long time.
So to balance the gravity
pulling the gas in,
we need to have something to
push it back at the gravity
and keep the star in balance.
And that forces pressure-- it's
the pressure of the hot gas
inside.
All those particles are
whizzing around its heat.
They collide into each
other, and those collisions
create pressure.
So once our star has
contracted enough
and warmed up enough
inside, there's
enough pressure for
that outward force
to balance the inward
force of gravity,
and the star's in
hydrostatic equilibrium.
But the star has a problem.
And this problem is absolutely
key to understanding
how stars work.
And it goes like this.
A star loses energy by shining.
Are you with me?
Stars shine.
Internal energy is what supports
the star against gravity.
So we're losing some
of this energy that's
supporting the star.
Losing that energy
reduces the pressure,
and that causes the
star to contract.
If the star contracts, it
makes gravity in the star
stronger because you're putting
all that mass closer together.
So now what happens to the
gas if it gets put in a higher
gravitational field?
Well, we can go look at the
solar system for a clue.
Here's a schematic--
a very bad schematic--
of the solar system.
If we go in closest
to the Sun, Mercury
is there, traveling
at 50 kilometers
a second around the Sun.
It's very close.
The gravity is
very strong there.
If we go further
out to the Earth,
where the gravity
isn't as strong,
the Earth is only moving
around the Sun at 30 kilometers
a second.
If we go even further out,
all the way to Jupiter,
where the gravity
is even weaker,
it's traveling at 13
kilometers a second.
So what you can
take away from this
is the stronger the gravity,
the faster the particles move.
It doesn't matter if particles
are planets or atoms in a gas.
So let's go back to our star.
When the gravity gets stronger,
the particles in the gas
move faster.
So what's faster
moving gas, faster
moving particles in a gas?
Heat.
That makes the star hotter,
which makes it shine brighter.
So you can see the problem.
It's a vicious circle.
The more energy it loses, the
hotter it gets, the brighter it
shines, and the faster
it loses energy.
Now this was recognized
back in the mid-19th century
by Kelvin in England and
Helmholtz in Germany.
And this was actually
a good thing,
they thought, because they
were wondering-- the geologists
at the time were saying, gee,
the Earth is several hundred
million years old at least.
And people asked, what kept
the Sun shining for so long?
They didn't know about
what we know today.
And so Kelvin and
Helmholtz suggested
that this is a way to
convert gravity into light
and make the Sun shine.
But then in about 1910,
Sir Arthur Eddington,
an astronomer in
England, computed
this would only last for
about 30 million years.
And by that time, the
geologists had figured out
the Earth was at least
a billion years old.
So there was something wrong.
And in 1938, Hans
Bethe figured out
what that something
wrong was and figured
out how to make the Sun shine.
And it provides a temporary, at
least, solution for our star.
So this happens very much
like in the Big Bang.
Inside the star, once the
star is contracted and warmed
up enough-- in this
case of the Sun,
about 15 million
degrees-- protons
whack together, form deuterium.
Another proton can
add on, form helium-3.
Two helium-3s can collide,
kick off a couple of protons
and make helium-4, much
like in the Big Bang.
And then that process converts
four hydrogens to one helium-4
and releases energy.
And that energy is what makes up
for the energy lost by the star
as it's shining.
Bethe won the Nobel Prize
in Physics in 1967 for this,
because that's actually a
pretty significant problem--
why does the Sun shine?
That deserves a Nobel prize.
So how does this work?
How do we get
energy out of that?
Well, it turns out four protons
by themselves weigh about 3%
more than when they're bound
together in a helium nucleus.
And when those
four protons fuse,
the difference between the mass
of the four protons themselves
and the mass as helium, that
3%, is converted into energy.
Remember E equals MC squared?
Mass and energy are equivalent,
as Einstein told us.
Now, that 3% doesn't
seem like very much.
But it's actually quite a lot.
If you take four pounds of
hydrogen, this much, and fuse
it, you get the
energy out of burning
a billion gallons of gasoline
or a million tons of TNT.
So it's actually a
very effective way
to produce energy.
So stars shine by
nuclear fusion,
this process of fusing
atoms together and making
heavier atoms out of them.
And the Sun fuses
about 630 million tons
of hydrogen per second.
Over on the other side there is
the Castle Bravo Nuclear Test.
That was an early
nuclear test in 1954
in the South Pacific
on Bikini Atoll.
And 60 pounds of hydrogen
were fused in an instant,
and it released 15
megatons of energy.
So you might ask yourself,
why doesn't the Sun blow up
the same way as that bomb?
Well, the Sun is contracted
and heated up just
until there was enough burning
to provide enough pressure
to counteract gravity.
If you were to make it
burn a little faster,
it would expand, cool down, and
the burning would slow down.
So there's a nice
thermostat that
keeps the star doing
just what you hope.
Over here, to make a bomb,
that's not what you want to do.
You want to heat the stuff up
so much, that it all burns,
all fuses.
I talk about burning.
I don't mean chemical burning.
I mean nuclear fusion.
It burns so fast, that it
all goes up in an instant,
and that's what you
want for a bomb.
But to get that to happen
in the nuclear test,
they had to heat the
hydrogen in that bomb
to 300 million degrees.
The Sun is only 15 million
degrees in its core.
So that's why the
Sun isn't a bomb.
It's a gradual
thermonuclear reactor.
But I said that this
was a temporary solution
to our star's problem.
And it is.
Eventually, the star's
going to run out
of hydrogen. It's
not going to have
any fuel left in the center.
So the Sun is 4.3 billion
years old at the moment.
You don't have to
worry about it.
It's not going to
run out of fuel yet.
It's going to last another
seven billion years or so.
And a star that's 5%
as massive as the Sun
will last more than a trillion
years, which is forever
to anybody but a cosmologist.
But consider a star that's a
lot more massive than the Sun,
maybe 25 times the
mass of the Sun.
It's got a lot more gravity.
It needs a lot more pressure
to balance that gravity,
so it's got to be a
lot hotter inside.
If it's a lot hotter, it
shines a lot brighter,
and it has to burn
its fuel faster
to make up for that lost energy.
So it turns out that a
massive star will run out
of fuel in something like 10
million years, which is almost
an eye-blink to an astronomer.
And so when it runs out of
fuel, what's it going to do?
It's going to start
contracting again and heat up.
That's the only thing it can do.
That's its problem again.
And when it heats
up enough, maybe
above 100 million degrees,
and density's over 1,000
grams per cubic centimeter
as it contracts,
it gets hot enough to
fuse helium together
to make this
isotope beryllium-8.
So two heliums collide
together, make up beryllium-8.
Beryllium-8 then gets hit
by helium-4 making a carbon.
Helium-4 hits the
carbon to make oxygen.
So now finally, we're making
some familiar elements--
carbon and oxygen.
So why, you ask, didn't
this happen in the Big Bang?
Well, it turns out
beryllium-8 is very unstable.
When you make it, when you
whack two heliums together,
the beryllium that forms
wants to break back up
into two heliums.
It wants to do so so fast,
that it only lasts for about 10
to the minus 21 seconds.
And in the Big Bang,
it wasn't very dense
and there weren't enough
reactions, weren't enough
collisions for helium
to hit the beryllium
before it decided to break
up again into 2 heliums.
In our star now, though,
it's a million times
denser than the Big Bang.
And so sometimes,
at least, there's
a helium around ready
waiting to hit that beryllium
before it decays.
And so this is
how helium burning
can produce carbon
and oxygen. And that
again, solves the star's problem
for a certain amount of time.
Now, when the Sun
runs out of helium,
it will, of course, start
contracting and heating up.
But before it actually
gets to the point
where the carbon atoms
can start fusing together,
it will actually
form a solid, a kind
of a solid out of that carbon
and oxygen in the middle.
And that solid will
provide pressure
that solves the problem
of the star forever.
It doesn't need heat anymore to
keep the pressure up and resist
gravity.
And so once that happens, the
outside layers of the star
keep burning for a while.
They run out of fuel eventually.
They go through some
various [? paroxysms ?]
and they're ejected
from the star.
And what you're left
with is a white dwarf,
a hot ball of carbon oxygen in
the center and a ring of gas.
That's the outside layers of the
star that have been expelled.
And it's called a
planetary nebula.
Now, the Sun will only
expel hydrogen and helium.
But stars slightly heavier
than the sun will actually
expel a little bit of carbon
and nitrogen. And that's good.
We've made some heavy
elements, and we've actually
put them back out in the
universe, where someday they
can form a planet
and maybe a person.
Except that a planet
or a person would
pretty boring with only
carbon and nitrogen.
So we're finally
getting somewhere,
but we're not there yet.
And I just can't
help showing you
some of these wonderful
images of planetary nebulae.
They're among the most beautiful
objects in the universe.
Here is, again, that
white dwarf in the center.
That dot is the hot
ball of carbon oxygen.
And you can see the
gas being thrown off
in shells as it runs out of
fuel on the outside of the star.
And that hot white
dwarf is so hot,
that it's shining in
the ultraviolet region
of the spectrum and ionizing
and exciting the gas
and causing the gas
around it to glow.
And here's another one.
The star in the middle is that
hot white dwarf left behind.
And the colored material
is the gas that's
been ejected from the star.
So for a star below 8 or 10
times the mass of the Sun,
that's the end of the line.
There's no more story.
The star never gets hot
enough to fuse carbon.
It ends up as a dead white
dwarf-- not very interesting.
So the next question
you might ask
is, how does he
know all this stuff?
[LAUGHTER]
You ever been to a star?
You ever been inside a star?
Not very likely.
So how do you know this?
Well, we can't do
experiments in astronomy.
Given the kind of
physical conditions
we deal with, you probably
don't want us doing experiments
in astronomy.
And all we can do is
thought experiments.
We can ask, what if?
It turns out the
universe is giving us
an enormous number of stars
of all different masses
in all different stages
of their evolution.
And so we can go and
try to piece together
what we see in different
places and come up
with a general
picture a theory that
allows us to synthesize all
this data into a coherent whole.
But we do this by
thought experiments
not by actually going
and actually doing
a real experiment.
In the last 60
years, computers have
become more and more
important to helping us
with these thought experiments.
We can't keep enough of
the data in our head.
And the models we
come up with get
to be more and more complicated,
and we can't work through them
without a computer.
And so this is a very large
computer at Lawrence Livermore
National Lab.
But the best
supercomputer center
I know of used for astronomy
is the one in Spain.
If you really want
to get inspiration
about what makes
the universe tick,
you put your supercomputer
center in a Romanesque church,
right?
This helps you get maybe just
a little extra inspiration.
[LAUGHTER]
So as you may have thought,
may have suspected,
the real story tonight
is in the massive stars,
the stars more massive than
about 10 times the Sun.
And here is the Pleiades.
Those of you who
drive a Subaru may
recognize this constellation,
this group of stars.
[LAUGHTER]
Subaru is Pleiades in Japanese.
And interestingly, the
Pleiades, the Subaru,
is in the constellation Taurus.
[LAUGHTER]
I've never quite
understood the connection.
But there must be
something deep in there.
[LAUGHTER]
In any event, these
are all massive stars,
stars greater than about 10
times the mass of the Sun.
And let's now try to follow
what their evolution looks like.
We've talked about
hydrogen. The star
starts out burning
hydrogen to helium.
In a massive star, it's maybe
more like 20 million degrees.
And this lasts about
10 million years.
It runs out of hydrogen.
It's starts fusing helium.
Helium burns at maybe
200 million degrees.
The star is hotter.
It's brighter.
It's got to make more energy
to make up for that luminosity
and so it burns faster.
This only lasts for
maybe a million years.
When it runs out of
helium, it starts
contracting and heating up
and starting to burn carbon.
Now, in carbon burning,
the star gets a problem.
Remember neutrinos,
those little particles
that can travel right through
the Earth without noticing?
Well, it turns out and gas
above about a half a billion
degrees the gas makes neutrinos.
And those neutrinos once
made, they leave the star.
So all of a sudden, the star
has a hole in it, in a sense,
for energy, right?
These neutrinos are carrying
away energy from the star.
So not only does
the poor star have
to burn its fuel to make up for
the light that's shining off
its surface, it
now has to make up
for all those neutrinos that are
carrying away energy as well.
And so it's got to burn
much faster and much hotter.
And carbon burning
only last 1,000 years.
When it runs out of carbon,
it contracts and heats up
to about 1.5 billion
degrees and starts
burning neon to make
oxygen, magnesium,
aluminum, phosphorus.
Now we're actually
getting somewhere.
We're really building
some elements.
This only last three years.
When it runs out of
neon, you guessed it,
it starts burning oxygen
at 2 billion degrees.
At this rate, it's really
making a lot of neutrinos,
and they're really robbing
the star from a lot of energy.
And so this only lasts
for eight months.
So you can see the
arc of the story here.
We're getting somewhere.
Something's about to happen.
But before we go
there, I just want
to talk to you
about how computers
have begun to really
play a major role in how
we view the physics that
goes on inside stars.
I'd say until about 10 or
15 years ago, most people
would think of these
nuclear burnings
as more like coals in a fire,
sort of a gentle reaction
producing heat, but not
a lot of action going on.
But now that we have
a big enough computer
to start simulating things
in three dimensions,
now that I can figure out how to
use this clicker-- there we go.
You can see-- this is
in silicon burning-- how
things are actually more
like a roaring fire, right?
Streams of sulfur are
rising up in here.
Fuel is falling down.
There's a lot of violent
activity [INAUDIBLE].
Back to our star.
The star runs out of
oxygen. It contracts
and heats up to
3.5 billion degrees
and starts to burn
silicon to iron.
But that's the end of the line.
That only takes a week.
And the star has now run
into a really big problem.
Because it turns out
you can take any element
you like lighter than
iron, fuse it together,
and they can't make energy.
Any element heavier
than iron, however, you
get energy out when
you break it up.
That's how the Palo Verde
Nuclear Plant works.
You take uranium, a
very heavy element,
break it up into smaller
pieces, called fission,
and get energy out.
So you can't burn iron.
So the star's run out
of any possibility
to make up the energy
its losing from neutrinos
and from its surface.
So here we are.
You might guess that
there's something
happening from the title.
Our star is now about 1,400
times as big as the Sun.
And it's mostly still hydrogen
and helium on the outside.
But in the center,
it's burned helium.
And in the inside that,
there's a little nugget
of carbon and oxygen. And then
inside that, neon, oxygen,
and magnesium.
These are all the burning
stages we've talked about.
Here we're already down to
only 10% the size of the Sun.
And in the middle, finally,
we have this silicon layer
and the iron core in the middle.
Now, that iron core, again,
finds itself in a quandary.
It's begun to contract.
It's begun to heat up.
But it can't do the same
thing it's done before.
It can't fuse iron
together to get energy out.
This is the Large Magellanic
Cloud, a small galaxy
that orbits the Milky Way.
It's about 150,000
light years away.
And if you look very
carefully, you'll
see the circle that
always appears in the sky
before something
important happens.
[LAUGHTER]
This is how we know
to go look there.
And on February 23, 1987, a star
in the Large Magellanic Cloud,
and it's the tiny little dot
right there not the big blob,
exploded.
And it exploded
because of the physics
I'll talk about in a minute
to do with this iron core.
And all of a, sudden, this
star, in less than a day,
started putting out
more than 250 million
times the luminosity of the Sun.
And that explosion
made 25,000 times
the mass of the Earth
of iron and even more
oxygen and other elements.
So this in fact, is
where the elements
are formed-- in supernovae,
in the explosions of stars.
And these explosions-- oh,
there's Time magazine, yes.
It's nice to see your
work on Time magazine.
They were a little slow.
If you notice the date
at the top is March 23.
They were about a month
late, but that's not bad.
And we'll also cut
them some slack.
Of course, there's no noise in
space, so it didn't go bang,
but at any rate.
So supernovae happen
every 100 years or so,
maybe a little more frequently,
in a typical galaxy.
And there are lots of
supernovae that people have
seen from Earth before now.
This is the remnant
of Kepler's Supernova.
It blew up in October 1604.
And Johannes Kepler
saw it and described it
as being brighter than
every star in the sky
except for Venus.
It's about 13,000
light years away.
And what you see in this image
is a quite remarkable image.
You see the gas expanding
at 20 million miles an hour,
spreading out.
It's about 14 light
years across by now.
And the blue light, the
blue in this picture
is actually X-rays from the
Chandra X-ray Satellite.
And that's where the
first gas, the fastest gas
is running into the gas around
the star in that galaxy,
in our galaxy.
The yellow and green is from
the Hubble Space Telescope.
And that's gas that's
inside the supernova
and has been warmed
up by the interaction.
And the red comes from the
Spitzer Space Telescope,
and it's dust.
It's heavy elements
inside that supernova
that have been warmed up and
are glowing in the infrared.
So this is as if you
could take your eyes
and expand the wavelengths
you can see from the X-ray
all the way to the infrared.
Worth spending a few billion
dollars on space telescopes?
I think so.
[LAUGHTER]
This is Supernova 1054.
It was seen by the Chinese
and a number of other places
around the world.
It's now called the Crab Nebula.
It's a bit closer at
6,500 light years.
And it was visible in
the sky for two years.
This is another supernova
remnant in Cassiopeia.
It's also expanding at about
11 million miles an hour.
It's 50 million degrees where
it's running into the gas
around it, this blue
part of the image.
And remarkably, it wasn't seen.
There's some possibility
that John Flamsteed saw it
in England but not likely.
It may have just been that
year was a very cloudy year,
and the chances of
seeing it were slim.
But in any event,
these explosions
do occur with some
frequency in the galaxy.
And let's find
out how they work.
So here we have a
diagram of the inner,
say, 100 miles or
so of this star.
So it's really a small
piece of the star.
And in the center here, in
the blue dot in the middle,
is this iron core.
It's just run out of silicon,
and it's sitting there.
It's now having to
contract and heat up.
In a few hours, it gets so hot,
that the iron nuclei that it's
made of begin to split
apart back down into protons
and neutrons and helium.
Now, the star just spent
the last 10 million years
putting it all together.
And it's gotten energy out.
So to split it
apart takes energy.
But where does that
energy come from?
The pressure.
Now, we've been talking so
far about gradual collapse.
When the star runs
out of fuel, it
gradually collapses and
shrinks down and warms up.
Now things happen in a
much faster time scale.
Once the nuclei
begin to break up,
the bottom falls
out of the star.
In 0.2 seconds, the
iron core collapses
from the size of the moon
to the size of Tucson.
It reaches a speed of about a
quarter of the speed of light.
And by the time it gets
down to the size of Tucson,
it's denser than
an atomic nucleus--
10 to 15 grams per
cubic centimeter
and a trillion degrees.
If you work that
out, Revelations
tells us that hell is a
burning lake of brimstone.
Well, sulfur, brimstone,
melts at about 500 degrees.
So it's about 2 billion
times hotter than hell.
[LAUGHTER]
But at any rate, it's
at a trillion degrees.
And at that density, the force
that holds nuclei together,
the strong nuclear
force, which is normally
attractive to nuclei,
becomes repulsive.
And so all of a
sudden, this huge mass
is falling in, more
or less in free fall.
Then all of a sudden,
there's an enormous pressure,
and it bounces.
And it starts bouncing out
at a significant fraction
the speed of light.
But of course the rest of the
star, like in an old cartoon,
doesn't know what's
happened yet.
And so it's still falling in.
And where they meet,
a shock wave forms.
And the shock wave
is trying to push
the star, in-falling
orange stuff,
back out as this inner
part of the star expands.
But as that material
falls through
from the rest of the star,
it too is heated up so much,
and it disintegrates
and takes energy away.
And so that shock wave is in
danger of being overwhelmed,
and the whole star
could collapse down
and form a black hole.
And large stars do that.
Stars more than about
40 or so solar masses
do, in fact, we think,
collapse to a black hole.
But for stars that are in the
intermediate range, between 10
and 40 or so solar masses, the
neutrinos come to the rescue.
This collapsing neutron
star, because now that's
what it's called-- its iron core
is turned into a neutron star--
radiates away roughly 25%
of its mass as neutrinos.
So for about a
second, that thing,
which is now the size of
Tucson, has a luminosity greater
than the entire rest of the
visible universe combined.
And even though neutrinos can
fly right through the Earth,
the density here is so
large that they're trapped,
and they begin to add energy
right behind that shock.
And they add energy
and rejuvenate it
and make up for
the energy that's
lost as it's dissociating the
material from the star that's
falling in.
And on a good day
on your computer,
this causes that material to
start convecting and roiling
and boiling, and eventually you
get an explosion-- not always.
This is something that we are
working very, very intently
on at the moment.
And we don't really
understand all
of the physics that goes on.
It's very, very complicated.
But here is the result
of a calculation.
I have to use the clicker
again to get the movie to play.
We can see this happening.
Here's the star falling in.
The shock wave
tries to move out,
but it gets overwhelmed
by the star.
And now it's sort
of in a balance.
But the neutrinos
are adding energy.
The star's continuing
to fall in.
But it's getting hotter and
hotter behind that shock.
And energy's building
up and building up
from these neutrinos.
And eventually, enough energy
gets imparted to this material
that it can actually move
on and blow the star apart.
Now, that took a
while on-- it actually
only took about 0.3 seconds
inside the supernova.
It also took about three months
to compute on a computer.
[LAUGHTER]
So we're not quite ready
to do real-time computing
for [? star ?] evolution yet.
Here's an image starting from
the configuration we left it
at, zooming out now so we
can see more of the star.
You can see that roiling
and boiling mass.
That's finally coming out.
The star's collapsing in.
Once it hits that
yellow, the in-fall
has turned into an outflow.
And this will continue out and
go all the way to the surface,
destroy the star, and
throw the material out
at tens of millions
of miles per hour.
As it does that, it
heats the start up
and actually burns it even more
and makes more new elements.
Whoops.
That's the wrong one.
Here's a 3-D version
of a similar model
for core collapse.
See the star collapses.
There's the shock wave.
It's slowing down.
The star's still falling in.
You can see now that
the inside of the star
is becoming convective.
It's roiling and boiling.
It's becoming unstable.
It's getting more
and more energetic
as this energy gets
imparted from the neutrinos.
You sit there watching
the output every day
from these computer
models-- blow!
Go on!
Do it!
[LAUGHTER]
This one looks kind of marginal.
I don't know.
It's taking a long time.
We're now up to,
what, 0.4 seconds.
Oh, now it's looking a
little more promising.
Well, maybe not.
It's torture to wait so
long for these things.
Now we zoom down a little bit.
And now finally, it's
getting to be larger.
Eventually, the
shockwave is going
to make it out and
blow up the star.
There it goes.
And that's what results.
That's the Crab Nebula again.
And inside in the blue,
you see an X-ray image
of the Chandra X-ray Satellite.
And in the middle there
is a spinning neutron star
with a very strong
magnetic field.
And it's spitting out
a very strong stream
of energetic particles
and whipping the gas
with its magnetic field and
heating it to tens of millions
of degrees.
And that thing is called a
pulsar, and that's left behind.
That's the object left behind.
That's why we know that
the Crab Nebula was
this kind of supernova.
That we saw the explosion,
that's pretty obvious.
But down in the middle is
a rotating neutron star
that was left behind.
That's that remnant
of that iron core
that you only get in
this kind of explosion.
Well, we talked about stars
bigger than 8 solar masses.
They develop iron cores.
The cores collapse.
On a good day on
the computer, they
explode, make lots of
elements, and send them out
into the universe, and
leave behind a neutron star
or a pulsar or a black hole.
We've also talked about stars
less than eight solar masses
that make a planetary
nebula and leave
behind a dead white dwarf.
Well, there's one more
twist to this story.
And that's if the white
dwarf has a companion,
if it's in a binary star
systems so the two stars are
going around each other.
In that case, they can
make a type Ia supernova.
And these are among the
brightest explosions
in the universe.
That's what Dave Arnett did.
He gave us the idea for
how these things work.
And a typical type Ia supernova
emits the Sun's whole lifetime
energy every second--
so as much energy
as the Sun will
produce overall it's
10 billion years of life, every
second, 30 million billion
billion billion megatons of TNT.
Isn't it fun to be
able to say that?
[LAUGHTER]
I looked for what the right
unit for that would be.
So I went out and
looked on Wikipedia
and found that the largest
prefix we have-- everybody
knows kilo and mega and giga.
Maybe if you buy a hard
disk for a computer
you know about tera nowadays.
But it turns out yotta is
the biggest prefix for 10
to the 24.
So this is 30 billion
yottatons of TNT.
[LAUGHTER]
Or if you like, that
many of those Castle
Bravo nuclear explosions.
But no matter how
you say it, the scale
is so far beyond
anybody's ability
to compare it to what
we know, that you just
have to sort of accept
the number of zeros.
But they're so
bright that you can
see these supernovae more than
halfway across the universe.
And in fact, it was
the measurements
of the distant supernovae
that first enabled
us to detect the
presence of dark matter
in the universe and the fact
that the universe was expanding
at an ever more rapid rate.
So here's a galaxy.
It's three pictures
of the same galaxy.
On the left, is a galaxy
before the supernova.
In the middle, is a supernova
after it's going off
at its peak brightness.
You can't really tell from
this image, but at the time,
that supernova is
putting out more light
than the entire rest
of the galaxy combined.
And then a little
bit later, you see
it's beginning to fade away.
Here's another galaxy.
We turn on the handy
cosmic indicator.
That's the supernova
right there.
By the way, the
reason we're building
this telescope,
the LSST, is to be
able to find these
supernova, because we don't
have the arrows, it turns out.
And so the only way to find
supernovae in enough quantity
to really study them is to go
out and look at the entire sky
as often as possible and compare
it with the previous night
and see where some new
bright object has appeared.
But for now, we'll
use the arrows.
Here's another spiral
galaxy with another type Ia
supernova in it.
So we can see these
throughout the universe.
And they're a very handy
tool for measuring distances
and doing cosmology.
But they're also very
handy for making elements.
This is how it works.
When the star's
in a white dwarf,
there's a companion
star, and they're
orbiting around each other.
And now we've got
our white dwarf,
because that star's
run out of fuel,
and we have a carbon oxygen
ball, that white dwarf.
And when its companion runs out
of fuel, runs out of hydrogen,
it swells up, starts burning
helium in the middle,
becomes a red giant.
The white dwarf can
suck some of the gas
off that companion star, and
it spirals in and ends up
adding to the mass
of the white dwarf.
And as the white
dwarf gets heavier,
it gets denser in the
middle and hotter.
And when it reaches a
special mass, 1.35 times
the mass of the Sun, something
called the Chandrasekhar mass,
it reaches about a
density of a few times 10
to the 9 grams per
cubic centimeter.
At that point,
carbon atoms finally
begin to fuse, even
in that low mass star.
And for about 1,000
years, it begins to fuse,
and the burning accelerates,
and it goes faster and faster.
And then one day, by dumb
luck, a small part of that star
begins to burn very rapidly.
It heats up strongly.
And within a few
seconds after that,
a thermonuclear explosion
engulfs the entire star,
turning it to iron, producing
30 billion tons of energy.
So here's a movie by
[? Casey ?] [? Meekin ?],
one of our post-docs
at Steward Observatory.
And this was this calculations
that were done at Chicago,
so Mike would be
happy about this.
[LAUGHTER]
Let me get my clicker.
The green here is a white dwarf.
And the little dot in the
middle is this burning part
that's just begun to burn.
And you'll see that as it begins
to burn, it becomes buoyant.
And the burning rises to the
surface like a mushroom cloud.
And then nuclear flames
spread out across the surface.
They get past the equator.
Once they get past
the equator, they
start coming together again.
And where they meet
at the antipode,
they ignite a detonation.
And that detonation wave,
then, destroys the star.
So here's the movie.
Here you see the burning begin.
The mushroom of hot gas that's
burning ever faster breaks
through the surface of the
star. [? It's happening. ?] It's
ignited down here
[? by ?] detonation.
In about a second,
the entire star's
engulfed and turned into iron.
So as I said, the type Ia
supernovae mostly make iron.
They turn the entire star
into iron and elements
near iron-- titanium,
chromium, vanadium, nickel,
cobalt, what have you.
And a typical explosion
of this kind of supernova
makes about 200 times
the Earth's mass in iron,
not much else.
But this iron
production is what's
responsible for most of the iron
tonight that you're sitting on
and the iron in your blood.
And interestingly, it doesn't
actually make it as iron.
It makes it as a radioactive
isotope nickel-56.
And nickel 56 decays to
cobalt-56 in about six days.
And about 77 days later, that
cobalt-56 decays to iron.
And so the iron
that's in your blood
and that you're
sitting on tonight
was once radioactive fallout
from a thermonuclear supernova.
And what you see halfway
across the universe
is, in fact, not that 30
billion yottatons of energy.
What you see is the glow
from the radioactive
decay of nickel to iron.
And there it is again.
We believe Kepler's Supernova
was a type Ia supernova.
And so it's expanding.
And in a few more thousand
years, 10,000 years,
that iron will get mixed in
with the gas of the galaxy
and have a chance
to form new stars.
So the origin the
elements is in stars
and in titanic explosions.
You can take the Sun
and ask, how much
of the material of
the sun would have
to have gone through a
supernova to reproduce
that set of elements we saw
at the beginning of the talk?
It turns out if
10% of the Sun has
passed through a
star in a supernova,
you would make the
chemical elements
we see inside the Sun today.
For you, it's much bigger.
90% of your body has
passed through a supernova.
So you really are stardust.
I won't sing.
[LAUGHTER]
So the elements
necessary for life
were created and are still being
created throughout the universe
by the evolution of stars and
the explosion of supernova.
So the stuff of
life is everywhere.
And if that's the
case, it's most likely
that life itself is everywhere.
And I'd like to
stop by going back
to our picture of the
star-forming clouds
and zoom out.
And you can see those three
fingers are down here just
below the center.
And in the green, this whole
region is forming stores.
But what's interesting
about this picture
is the red is hot
gas left behind
from a supernova that occurred
a few thousand years before.
So a star there formed
elements, blew up,
scattered those elements
out into new gas,
probably bumped the gas enough
to get it to start collapsing.
And that gas there
is now collapsing,
forming new stars, new planets,
and who knows who else.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
And I think we have a few
minutes for just a couple
of questions, if
anybody would want
to talk about nuclear bombs.
[LAUGHTER]
Did I get the right impression
that the stars or the suns
rotate, like the Earth?
Stars themselves rotate,
just like the Earth, yes.
And in fact, the
rotation of stars
can actually affect the
mechanism of the explosion
of the supernova.
That's one of the things
that we're working on today.
So our own sun rotates?
Our own sun rotates.
Oh, I never knew that.
Thank you.
Has anybody looked
at the possibility
of just how many supernovas
have created the heavier
elements, say, [INAUDIBLE]?
Oh, [? great ?] number.
You can actually ask,
what is the amount
of mass in the universe?
I mean just on the Earth.
Oh, just for the Earth?
Yeah.
Well, it would take much
less than one supernova
to create enough heavy
elements to make the Earth.
But more likely than
not, many supernovae
contributed to the heavy
elements in the Earth
by mixing their production
in the gas in the galaxy.
So that's happened over quite
a long time and travelled quite
a ways.
That's right.
What is a black hole?
[LAUGHTER]
Ooh, a black hole-- I'm going to
go the short, technical answer
and avoid the question.
A black hole is
a region of space
where the escape
velocity is greater
than the speed of light.
And since nothing can travel
faster than the speed of light,
nothing can leave that region.
And what goes on
inside that black hole,
we can't know because no
information can get out
to tell us.
It's an interesting
philosophical question
as to whether
that's even science,
because you can't do
an experiment in there
to find out.
But so what happens when
a massive star collapses?
It gets smaller and smaller and
denser and denser and denser,
until the gravity is so strong
that light can't get out
anymore from that area.
And that's a black hole.
What happens to the companion
star of a Ia supernova?
It has quite a ride.
[LAUGHTER]
Remarkably, it does
not get destroyed.
And there a number of people who
have been doing models of this.
It gets stripped of its
outer layers of gas.
It gets heated up somewhat.
It probably bounces
around in rings
because it gets
whacked pretty hard.
But it pretty much remains
intact, remarkably enough.
Have you met Chandra Sekhar,
and he's a cool dude?
I have not met Chandra Sekhar.
Dave has.
I have not, I'm afraid.
Where do the
meteorites come from,
and does their
composition tell us
anything about these
supernova explosions?
Absolutely.
So we start out
with all this gas
in those dark clouds we saw.
They collapse.
They form a star.
Some of the gas forms
a disk around the star.
And out of that disk,
the heavy elements
condense and form rocks.
Those rocks combine together.
And that's basically the
history of how you make planets,
in a nutshell.
But not everything
goes into planets.
Some of it stays as
little rocks, as dust.
And those little
rocks and that dust
are asteroids and
smaller objects
going around the solar system.
And every once in a
while, one of them
gets whacked by the gravity of
Jupiter or some other planet
and deflected and eventually
comes and hits our atmosphere.
So that's a sample ready
made, delivered right to us
on Earth of the primordial
stuff out of which
the solar system was made-- this
stuff that the supernova had
produced.
And so it's a great help to
us to look at these asteroids
and actually be able to
measure the relative amounts
of different isotopes in them.
There's quite a lot of
very interesting stuff
analogous to look at tree
rings for nucleosynthesis
that you get from meteorites.
Black holes don't emit
anything by definition.
However, as stuff falls
into a black hole,
it goes from a very large
volume to a much smaller volume,
and it gets squeezed.
And it can squeeze and get
sufficiently hot to emit X-rays
just before it
falls down the hole.
So in a sense, black holes
don't themselves emit.
But the system that contains
a black hole can emit X-rays.
That's right.
So if anybody else
wants to listen to--
You haven't--
Oh, one more question.
You haven't talked about
formation of the elements
heavier than iron, such as
uranium and [? latitium. ?]
And is the reason why beryllium
is so rare in the universe
because beryllium-8
is so unstable.
Yes to the latter one.
The former question-- where do
the elements heavier than iron
come from?
It's a much more
difficult subject.
It goes basically like this.
There are two sets of
elements heavier than iron.
One of them gets produced
down inside that red region
inside the star,
that shock that's
being heated by the neutrinos.
That's something
called the r-process.
And the way that
works is there's so
many free neutrons in
that gas, they just
keep adding more
and more neutrons
on to the nuclei that are there.
And every once in a
while, one of those
neutrons turns into a
proton, and the thing
keeps building up to heavier and
heavier and heavier elements.
And that's the rapid
process, because that
happens all in a small
fraction of a second.
There's another
analogous process called,
you guessed it, the s-process,
or the slow process,
where in helium
burning in some stars,
heavy elements that
are already there,
iron, for example,
that's already there,
can slowly absorb more
neutrons and build up
to heavier and heavier nuclei.
But both of those arr a
much more complicated story,
and so I figured
we'd start with stick
with the gratuitous
violence tonight.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, thank you very much, Phil.
Thank you, again.
[APPLAUSE]